et quand on prend euh quand on exprime
son soutien à voilà à Gaza ou à Israël
euh bien ça fait beaucoup de remous et
Karim Benzema
euh l'a su là dernièrement puisque ça a
pris une ampleur nationale l'affaire
Karim Benzema c'est l'affaire du jour
dimanche en fin d'après-midi Karim
Benzema a exprimé son soutien aux
habitants de Gaza sur X toutes nos
prières pour les habitants de Gaza
victime une fois de plus de ces
bombardements injustes qui n'épargne ni
femme ni enfants il a ensuite publié un
nouveau poste lundi en fin d'après-midi
une question de mentalité parce que
derrière il y a eu énormément de
réaction concernant le poste de Karim
Benzema donc il a montré voilà il a v
montré qu'il avait le dos assez large
pour supporter les critiques et derrière
Géral daranin le ministre de l'Intérieur
euh il a fait un post qui a fait bah en
fait il a fait une sortie qui a fait
énormément réagir puisque euh Géral
d'Anin regardez ce qu'il a dit sur Karim
Benzema et aujourd'hui la sénatrice CLR
Valérie Boyer elle a demandé la
déchiance de nationalité du joueur de
foot ça a pris une ampleur incroyable
très très considérable regardez ce qu' a
dit Géral Darman nous avons fermé 1100
établissements islamistes et depuis
quelques semaines je m'intéresse
particulièrement Monsieur benzama est en
lien on le sait tous notoire avec les
Frères musulmans nous attaquons à une
hydre qui sont les Frères musulmans
parce qu'il donneent un djihadisme
d'atmosphère comme le disait Gill
kepppel Valérie Boyer sénatrice LR est
avec avec nous merci d'être avec nous
Valérie Boyer alors l'information vient
de tomber sachez que le joueur Karim
Benzema envisage de porter plainte
contre le ministre de l'Intérieur il a
réagi ce soir aux accusations de giralde
harmanin par l'intermédire de son avocat
Maître Hugé HUG Vigier nous
réfléchissons à des poursuites à
l'encontre de ce ministre en application
par exemple de la loi sur la
manipulation de l'information chè à
notre gouvernement et de la diffamation
voire de l'injure publique parce que le
lien inexistant avec les Frères
musulmans qu'il dit pourtant notoire est
évidemment présenté comme dépréciatif il
n'est pas acceptable que ceux qui
gouvernent se ci autorisé à tout par pur
opportunisme c'est ce qu'a dit le
l'avocat de de Karim Benzema Karim
Benzema va également porter plainte
contre l'eurodéputé Nadine Morano et
contre le publicitaire Franck tapirot la
première et en qualifier le joueur
d'agent de propagande du Hamas le second
ayant estimé qu'il était un collabo
complice du
terrorisme
et prier le 15 octobre pour des
populations civiles sous les bombes qui
n'épargneent ni les femmes ni les
enfants ne constituent évidemment ni
propagande pour le Hamas ni complicité
de terrorisme ni acte de collaboration
estime son avocat c'est c'est je veux le
croire la compassion naturelle en face
de ce que beaucoup qualifient
aujourd'hui de CRIM de guerre qui se
commettent à Gaza mais qui n'enlèvent
rien à l'horreur des actes terroristes
du 7 octobre qui ne se discute pas en
employant ces termes scandaleux à son
égard Nadine Morano et Franck tapirot
ont porté une atteinte profonde et
insupportable à son honneur je lis euh
voilà les les les propos bien sûr de de
l'avocat de Karim Benzema on va voir les
dé
et déclarations
dead h géométrie variable c'est plus un
dommageutre chose c'est hte surtoutelun
comme benzjà par le
passé sur le terrain moment de la
Marseillaise voilà aujourd'hui beaucoup
de il est pas comme ça mais est comme ça
il faut dire il est complice du
terrorisme c'estab il n aucune
compassion pour les enfants
décapité sur le territoire d'Israël pour
ces femmes violées il parle de femmes et
d'enfants pour ces jeunes qui faisaient
la fête qui ont été décimé il a choisi
son camp en écrivant uniquement cela en
fait il est un élément de propagande du
Hamas il a craché sur la Marseillaise
parce qu'il dit qu'il avait pas craché
sur la Marseillaise il dit qu'il n'aime
pas la Marseillaise et bien là il nous
crache dessus une seconde fois et donc
il vit en Arabie Saoudite il est bien en
Arabie Saoudite il a choisi son camp
nous nous choisissons le camp de la
démocratie alors je vous ai lu la
réponse de l'avocat de Karim Benzema et
hier soir donc le ministre de
l'Intérieur je vous ai dit a déclaré que
Monsieur Karim bzema est en lien on le
sait tous notoire avec les Frères
musulmans le cabinet du ministère de
l'Intérieur s'est expliqué à la suite
des propos de Gerard daranin depuis
plusieurs années nous constatons une
lente dérive des prises depposition de
Karim Benzema vers un islam dur
rigoriste caractéristique de l'idéologie
frériste consistant à diffuser les
normes islamiques dans différents
espaces de la société notamment dans le
sport il reproche au joueurs de chanter
la Marseillaise d'avoir refusé de
chanter la Marseillaise alorsqu'il était
en équipe de
France voilà et le joueur de foot
s'était justifié à ce propos il avait
déclaré à vantifer si vous écoutez bien
la Marseillaise appelle à faire la
guerre et ça ça ne me plaît pas c'est ce
qu'avait dit Karim Benzema merci Valérie
Boyet d'être avec nous vous êtes
sénatrice les républicains et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde n'a parlé
que de vous Valérie je sais pas si ça
vous aviez envie qu'on parle autant de
vous aujourd'hui mais ça a été fou euh
puisque vous êtes sénatrice l' des
bouche duô et vous avez demandé la
déchiance de nationalité de Karim
Benzema pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi vous
êtes allé aussi loin pourquoi j'ai dit
que si les propos de Gérald daranin étai
avérés donc sil éta s'ils avaient la
gravité qu'il disaient ce matin s'il
avait des éléments à ce moment-là il
fallait aller plus loin parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit
j'aiécouté votre émission en arrivant
effectivement on on ne parle que de ce
conflit
abominable qui fait suite au plus grand
pogrom qu'on est connu depuis la 2uxem
Guerre mondiale parce qu'il y a jamais
eu autant de Juifs tué que depuis le 7
octobre et qu'aujourd'hui et bien on a
la situation que nous connaissons en
Israël et dans la bande de Gaza qui
affecte tout le monde je me permets
juste et je répondrai précisément à
votre question de vous dire que hélas
c'est pas le seul conflit qui endeuille
notre planète aujourd'hui puisque nous
nous assistons à une sorte
de les dictatures contre les démocraties
qui se passe ça se passe en Israël on en
parle beaucoup on ne parle pas de la
guerre du Yémen aujourd'hui qui depuis
10 ans ravage ce pays faitre des
maladies qui ne qui avait disparu ou des
enfants meurent de faim où le pays est
vraiment dans un état abominable c'est
probablement avec la République la RDC
un des pays les plus durs du monde la
démocratie oui vra et ça personne n'en
parle jamais on ne parle pas non plus de
ce qui se passe en Arménie où le pays
est menacé dans son intégrité
territoriale là ce n'est plus le carabak
qui a été qui a subi une épuration
ethnique c'est la République d'Arménie
qui est menacée dans son existence avec
des dictateurs comme aliaf et Erdogan
qui menacent tous les Arméniens et qui
veulent je les cite les chasser comme
des chiens on n'en parle pas on ne parle
pas non plus des menaces de la Chine sur
Taïwan qui qui sont du même Akabi où
nous avons et j'oublie probablement des
conflits nous avons donc les les
dictateurs une espèce d'internationale
des dictateurs contre les démocraties et
c'est ce qui se passe aussi en Israël et
c'est ce qui se passe aussi en Europe
d'une certaine façon quand on a Chypre
qui est qui est occupé depuis
1974 et des îles grecques qui sont
menacées dans ce contexte vous allez me
dire dans ce
contexte où vendredi 13 nous avons eu
une des des es et des terroristes qui
ont demandé des actions et ces actions
ont été conduites puisque nous pleurons
aujourd'hui après Samuel paatti nous
pleurons la mort d'un professeur
courageux à aras qui a été assassiné par
un enfant qui avait été élevé en France
logé nourri blanchi éduqué en France et
qui est allé tuer son un professeur dans
le lycée où il avait été éduqué et le de
quelques jours après et bien nous avons
eu ces deux pauvres suppors suédois qui
ont été assassinés à Bruxelles donc les
paroles comptent et quand le ministre de
l'Intérieur ce matin tient des promos
c'est pas n'importe qui je veux dire on
n'est pas dans une émission ou dans au
café du commerce et cetera on a le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui répond un
journaliste dans une émission politique
et qui parle de cette personne qui est
mondialement connue puisque le foot
c'est mondialement connu en tenant des
propos qui sont graves Karine Benzema
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
dit mais si c'est le cas je pense qu'il
faut aller plus loin parce par qu'
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas avoir de
complaisance avec le terrorisme
maintenant j'entends que Monsieur
Benzema fait appel de cette décision
et cette de ces propos pardon et
effectivement B on verra ce que la
justice dira aujourd'hui mais enfin on
est dans un état de tension qui est
extrême et un ministre de l'Intérieur
qui dit ça pour une personnalité pareil
je pense qu'il faut aller jusqu'au bout
parce que non seulement ce sont des
grands champions mais en plus ce sont
des afflu ur extrêmement important vous
vous êtes sûr que que Karim Benzema a un
lien avec les Frères musulmans est-ce
qu'il y a des preuves est-ce qu'il y a
des choses ou pas bah écoutez moi je
suis pas ministre de l'Intérieur je ne
suis pas enquêteur et c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai interrogé le le
ministre de l'Intérieur et je lui ai
demandé où en est-on qu'est-ce qui se
passe si vous avez tenu ses propos il
faut pas enfin on peut pas balancer
excusez-moi de ce terme un peu trivial
de tels propos sans aller jusqu'au bout
de la
démarche alors on a des outils
juridiques clairement aujourd'hui mais
par exemple on n a pas pour ce que
Gilles kpel a appelé le djihadisme
d'atmosphère aujourd'hui enfin néanmoins
moi ma seule interrogation c'était de
dire euh si si ce que vous dites si donc
si si ce que vous dites monsieur le
ministre ben il faut aller plus loin et
engager une action pour justement et
bien faire en sorte que cette personne
ne puisse plus tenir ce type de propos
ou avoir des actions qui menacent la
sécurité des Français puisque nous
sommes en guerre contre le terrorisme
c'est pas moi qui le dis c'est tout le
monde qui le dit et donc il faut aller
plus loin si donc ce qu' dit le ministre
de l'Intérieur donc Karim Benzema donc
il a pas dit grandchose he pardonnez-moi
si si non mais non mais il dit qu'il y a
des liens il dit je le suis depuis
plusieurs semaines et c'est notoire il y
a des liens entre Karim Benzema et les
Frères musulmans ce qui surprend parce
que Karim Benzema joue en Arabie
Saoudite qui considèent que les Frères
musulmans sont une organisation
terroriste et c'est vrai qu'on a la
France et j'espère que ce sera le cas
alors vous j'imagine que comme moi vous
avez lu le livre de Madame Florence
berge bler et il faut absolument que
toutes ces organisation terroriste soit
interdite en France bien évidemment et
j'espère que ce sera bientôt le cas gen
sur Karim Benzema restons sur alors ce
ce qui surprend un peu c'est que le
ministre a été très loin alors est-ce
qu'il a effectivement ce qu'on appelle
en langage journalistique des billes
c'est des informations qu'il sortira un
peu plus tard et qu' ou alors est-ce
qu'il s'est engagé sur un terrain un peu
aventureux on ne sait pas c'est vrai que
vous avez réagi très vite très très vite
moi ce qui mceé surprise oui vous
demandez la déchéance de d'un français
né en France don j'ai dit j'ai dit que
oui mais c'est c'est on a on a j'ai dit
que on pouvait toujours la demander
parce que je pense que
symboliquement dans la situation dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons si le
ministre de l'Intérieur a raison je
pense que c'est des réflexions que nous
devons avoir parce que ce n'est pas
possible d'avoir aujourd'hui la
situation en France la situation
mondiale la situation en Europe on est
quand même presque 300 morts directes du
terrorisme chez nous hein on a je ne
sais pas combien d'actes antisémites par
jour des menaces vous-même vous parliez
tout à l'heure des menaces dont vous
avez fait l'objet on est nombreux
malheureusement à faire des à être
victime de
menaces je pense que un moment donné il
faut aller plus loin et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je j'ai interrogé le
ministre de l'Intérieur pour lui dire
euh est-ce que vous avez est-ce que vous
avez des B vous Luz demandé est-ce que
vous avez des B fa aller lo vous répondu
j'attends d'accord vous l'
interrogé çaté un défer cet après-midi
cet après-midi nous avons eu des
explications du ministre de l'Intérieur
qui dit bah oui j'ai dit ça mais pour
l'instant j'ai pas d'outil donc moi j'ai
toujours un une petite difficulté enfin
une grosse difficulté pardon de cette
litote quand on est un responsable
politique et
que on on dit quelque chose et qu'on
peut pas aller vers vers cette chose ça
crée quand même une confusion qui est
importante mais est-ce que est-ce que
Gérald daranin Jacques cardos aurait dit
ça s'il n'avait aucune billeespère que
j'ose espérer qu'il a des éléments
c'est il laisse entendre il laisse
entendre dans son propos que il suit les
agissements de Monsieur Benzema depuis
un certain temps donc lui seul a entre
guillemets la main sur les services de
renseignement est est-ce que vous
trouvez ici autour la table pose la
question aussi chez vous et vous valirez
aussi est-ce que vous trouvez il y en a
beaucoup qui disent aussi que c'est
disproportionné par rapport à la
réaction qu'a eu Karim Benzema sur les
réseaux est-ce que vous trouvez ça ou
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec les
gens qui disent au contraire c'est Karim
Benzema n'aurait pas dû faire ce genre
de publication et il y en a beaucoup
aussi qui disent voilà on trouve ça un
peu ça fait une affaire d'état est-ce
que c'est disproportionné pour vous
est-ce qu'il y en a qui trouvent ça
normal vous non mais moi ce que ce qui
me semble évident c'est qu' c'est un des
tneurs de l'équipe de France or l'équipe
de France elle c'était elle l'équipe de
France elle représente la France or la
France est divisée donc je vois pas
pourquoi l'équipe de France échapperait
à cette division des esprits des raisons
et des cœurs entre deux camps qui
s'affrontent donc voilà ils ont ils sont
c'est pas une troupe qui marche comme ça
en filindienne voilà il est moi je ne
doute pas que que j derman ait des
informations j'espère en tout cas ça
serait grave c'est ministère de un
ministre de l'Intérieur balancer des
infos comme ça aussi grav sans infos
mais voilà ça serait pas étonnant que
l'équipe de France soit aussi divisée
que la population donc oui mais donc oui
mais vous la déchance de nationité vous
avez pas répondu à ma questionoui c'est
disproportionné bah oui il faut mettre
les choses dans leur contexte tout parle
d'un tweet dans lequel Karim Benzema
soutient les civils palestiniens à aucun
moment il dit qu'il ne soutient le Hamas
ce ce qui lui est reproché vous avez
rien compris excusez-moi excuse-i qui
lui est reproché surtout c'est de ne pas
avoir un mot pour le professeur qui
s'esté à aras non non mais c'est ça
surout et pour qui s'est passé mais
c'est pas parce qu'il n'a pas un mot
qu'il ne condamne pas c'est ça que je
veux dire et on fait des
raccourcis de choses
ches ça
pr la dé
deité pas dit ça on va revenir sur ce
qu' dit Val s plat minutes de petites
secondes arrêter de parler d'échéances
de nationalité ce que dit ce qu' dit
Valérie Boyer on le répète c'est si dit
Gard Darmanin est confirmé elle demande
une déchéance de nationalité donc qu'on
engage qu'on engage il faut c'està dire
qu'il faut aller plus loin et qu'on
réfléchiss je veux dire c'est c'est
c'est des propos d'une extrême gravité
que le ministre de l'Intérieur a tenu
sur une personne dans le contexte dans
lequel nous sommes donc à un moment
donné on peut pas on peut pas être au
milieu du gay il faut aller plus loin al
justement alors rmon dis-nous toi est-ce
que tu trouves que c'est dis fait
quelque chose avec les Frères musulmans
ou quelqueose qui soit punis par la on
le punit par la loi et on le sanctionne
par la loi c'est un enfant qui est né en
France il est français de naissance on
va pas enlever la nationalité il
nationalité qui après il devient quoi
pakistanais pien ça c'est fait c'est le
premier débat après je r moi j'enlève
pas la nationalité de quelqu'un qui est
en France enfant c'est pas c'est pas
quelqu'un qui a une autre nationité qui
dans un autre pays c'est un enfant de la
France il a ses bureaux sa société
pendant des années en France à Lyon ça y
est ça on passe le tweet maintenant le
tweet je trouve que s'il veut c'est bien
de de donner le Stien et la force à Gaza
et à la Palestine ce qui me dérange moi
comme vous avez dit tout à l'heure c'est
un influenceur c'est quelqu'un qui est
mondialement connu avec des millions
d'abonnés ce qui me dérange c'est que
tous les musulmans qui souffrent quand
il y a des attentats et on dit toujours
faut faut pas faire d'amalgame il aurait
pu faire un tweet pour dire je condanne
ce qui s'est passé en Belgique parce que
là c'est pas le Hamas c'est pas la
Palestine c'est pas
Isra le professur même le prof non mais
excuse-moi excuse-moi céit c'était après
la Belgique là tu dis des bêtises non il
peut pourquoi il peut pas faire de tweet
là pour ce qui s'est pass en là c'est
surtout le
professeur alors eu le professeur et
aussi pour dire à tous les musulmans et
dire à tout que nous on dit pas
d'amalgame il faut dire aussi que lui
qui a de la puissance il pourrait dire
je condamne ce qui s'est passé en
Belgique tous les musulmans ne sont pas
des terroristes arrêtez de faire des
amalgames il prend pas position
là-dessusant c'est en Belgique et c'est
des Suédois ça rien à voir avec le
conflit ni en Palestine en Israël il
aurait pu prendre position là-dessus
c'est ça que je reproche moi ce qui
s'est passé ça à voir avec probablement
les ordres qui ont été donnés de faire
du vendredi 13 une journée du Jihad je
veux
dire oui oui vendred d'cord d'accord
d'accord pour la je
pensais autre chose me là vous allez
loin oui mais c'est d'accord j'ai
compris Val juste Karim Benzema ça a été
un
déferlement est-ce que vous trouvez que
c'est il y en a qui trouvent que c'est
normal a qui trouvent que c'est
disproportionné dites-nous oui moi je
trouve que c'est disproportionné et
quand bien même son tweet n'était pas
complet j'ai une question aujourd'hui
les fichiers s en France est-ce que
quand ils sont fichers s on le retire la
nationalité française non aujourd'hui ah
d'accord c'est tout ce que je voulais
savoir donc c'est là qu'on voit qu'en
fait Karim BZ il est pris en exemple et
c'est juste n'importe quo vous avez deux
types de vous avez deux types de
fichiers les fichiers s les fichiers
srpt c'est des personnes qui sont
surveillées euh avec différents degrés
de gravité mais je peux vous dire que
par exemple quand on est mère par
exemple comme comme j'ai pu l'être vous
ne pouvez pas savoir si vous embauchez
quelqu'un si ces personnes sont plus
ou
vous êtes en train de dire que par
exemple Karim Benzema serait plus
dangereux pour la France qu'un fichier s
puisquon lui retirerit la nationalité
doncès bien dire vous des grandes
informations sur lui et nous les dire
par absol pas par dit que si les propos
du ministre de l'Intérieur revêent la
gravité qu'il a exprimé euh ce matin
c'était pas pour rien bah non j'en sais
rien je n'en sais rien madame si c'était
pour rien ou pas je ne suis ni enquêteur
j'ai la même information que vous je
n'en sais rien je pense qu'il faut je
pense qu'il faut aller plus loin
effectivement nous parlons là de deux
personnes qui sont des personnes
particulièrement qualifiées et
importantes nous avons une personne qui
est un joueur de foot qui est
mondialement connu et nous avons le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui est la
personne la mieux informée de France
donc voilà donc on ne peut pas
exc pas pouron
comprne il peut pas non plus
dévoilerit
une pour que tout le monde comprenne
bien qu'il y a un lien et vous le dites
dans votre communiqué entre les Frères
musulmans et le
Hamas se pose la question maispr c'est
vrai que ça a pris une ampleur le tweet
de Karim Benzema il y a beaucoup de gens
qui disent c'est
disproportionné aprè vous avez raison le
ramas est une organisation terroriste à
caractère religieux effectivement et
c'est très important de le dire oui
c'est vrai cré par un frériste créé par
un frériste oui merci on va voir
j'aimais bien voir ce qu'on pens les
téléspectateurs s'il vous plaît c'est
pas une organisation de libération bah
ils ont rien mis bon ben très bien ah
voilà
si merci bon très bien sur le sondage de
20h de SD merci en tout cas Valérie
Boyer d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous
d'avoir réagi et voilà c'est bien que et
j'espère que le les les les suites qui
sont qui ont qui ont été donné vont
éclaircir cette situationû ça va être ça
va être éclairci merci à tous tout de
suite moncheville sur
C8